اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط
واصابه 17 ضابطا وجنديا في معارك بالقطاع
خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه بينما اعلن ابو
عبيده الاجهاز على 22 جنديا وتدمير 42
اليه اسرائيليه خلال الاسبوع الماضي مع
استمرار القذف الاسرائيلي على مناطق
متفرقه من قطاع غزه سقوط شهداء وجرحى
بينهم اطفال ونساء في قصف على منازل في
جباليا شمالا ورفح جنوبا ما يرفع عدد
الشهداء الى
147 خلال
4 ساعه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يعلن
الاتفاق مع اسرائيل على ارسال بعثه امميه
الى شمال غزه لتقييم الاوضاع بشان عوده
السكان والبيت الابيض يق يقول ان واشنطن
لا تؤيد وقف اطلاق النار وانها تدعم هدنا
اضافيه لايصال المساعدات في حين اكدت تل
ابيب عزمها على الاستمرار في القتال حتى
الوصول الى قاده حماس واعاده الاسر
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه مصدر عسكري
في اليمن يقول ان انصار الله الحوثييين
استهدفوا سفينه في البحر الاحمر والقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه تعلن ان طائره
وسفنا امريكيه وبريطانيه اسقطت 18 صاروخا
ومسيره في حين يصوت مجلس الامن اليوم على
مشروع قرار امريكي يدين هجمات الحوثيين
ويؤكد حق الدول في الدفاع عن سفنها الى
اللقاء